(tinny upbeat music)
- Woo hoo, April, baby!
Okay, so I just saw on this site
that rhubarbs are in season now.
Finally, I'm gonna make a pie.
I thought you
wanted to make pie?
Are you all right?
- I have to say something, Abbi.
It's hard to say, but (sighs)
I just feel like
we've been hanging out
too much lately.
I mean, it's been
like all the time,
every fuckin' day.
Are we even individuals
any more, you know?
Or are we just one fused brain?
We've reached a
tipping point and,
this is the hardest part!
But
I think we need a
break, a friend break,
where we take a week off
of talking, texting,
phone conversation and even
IRL hangs.
No letters, no cards.
A friend break, just
for a week. (sighs)
- You know what?
I've kind of been
feeling the same way.
I think that this is
a really great idea.
- Are you kidding?
That was an April Fool's!
You were supposed to go,
"Oh, my God, never,
I'd die for you!"
and then I'd be
like, April Fool's!
But you really feel that way?
- No, no no,
I was kidding!
April Fool's! (yelling)
You got fooled, you the fool!
Foolish, yay, we play.
Oh, man.
I win, I'm the fool king!
- Oh, you got me, dude.
- Woo!
- We did the same April
Fool's, oh my God.
I feel even closer.
We gotta hang out
every day forever.
Otherwise I'm gonna blow
brains out. (imitates gun)
- Not if I blow mine out
first.
- Oh.
Okay, I'm comin' over.
- That sounds great.
See ya soon.
(tuts) Really didn't
need to smash the bowl.
(tinny upbeat music)